hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar hi through put crispr editing
using the onyx platform identities
essential residues
in proteins i'm susie valdez of labrutz
and i will be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by elaborates and brought to
you
by inscripta to learn more visit
inscripta.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting as many questions as
you want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speakers dr
elisa lot
de wachter post doctoral research fellow
and dr
laura clinton scientific liaison
at emea for inscripta welcome to both of
you
dr clinton you may now begin your
presentation
welcome
thank you very much to lab roots for
giving me the opportunity to introduce
to you the online class
and how interesting enables genome
engineering on a massive scale
i'm laura kitten the scientific liaison
at inscripta anemia
and i act as the link between scientists
in europe and my colleagues in the us
in scripps's goal is to empower
scientists whose gene editing research
is stifled by current technical and
licensing limitations
and by providing our unique platform and
engaging in collaborative business
practice
such as making math 7 chris our math 7
crispr nucleus
free for research and development
purposes we enable scientists
to realize a new era of biological
discovery
we are headquartered in boulder colorado
with offices in pleasanton california
and san diego in the u.s
inscripta is backed by leading investors
including venrock
foresight paladin capital group and
malaya development
here in europe i'm your local contact
person so please feel free to reach out
to me by mail phone or social media
if you have any questions whatsoever
i've listed my twitter linkedin and
email so you know where
to find me
to add in scripture we strongly believe
in the power of biology to change the
world
and what we've seen over the past decade
is that biology has become
increasingly important in all of these
areas from
engineered strains that produce
antibodies or small molecules
to engineered strains that produce the
key ingredient of the impossible burger
two other strains of breakdown plastics
or other byproducts
and this trend is just going to continue
we believe over the next decade
so really our ability to understand how
biology works and use that knowledge to
engineer biology to
create new desirable phenotypes we
believe is going to drive advancements
in all of these sectors of the economy
and a key thing to both
understanding biology and engineering
biology is our ability to manipulate
genomes and in particularly
our ability to manipulate genomes in
high throughput
so there are a number of current
approaches for doing high high
throughput genome manipulate
manipulation
so you can do classical mutagenesis
knockout libraries or crispai or
crispr-a libraries
but all of these approaches while very
beneficial in certain scenarios they do
come
with some trade-offs and those
trade-offs are depicted over in the
thought on the left
so either an approach will typically
allow you to assess
a lot of locations in the genome for
example when you're doing classical
mutagenesis or genome-wide nerve-outs
or it will allow you to make a diverse
range of edit types if you are doing for
example protein or pathway engineering
but it's difficult to target both a lot
of genomic locations with a lot of
diverse edit types in the same
experiment
and there are additional challenges with
these current approaches
so they suffer from lack of precision
they can have slow or laborious
workflows that often require substantial
automation
to achieve high throughput it can be
difficult to separate hitchhike
limitations
and if you're working on a plasmid then
you can have issues with transient
expression
and changes due to the marker or the
expression system itself
so what we really want to unlock is this
upper right quadrant here
and also overcome these different
challenges to have a reliable
high throughput method for manipulating
genomes to advance
all of the before mentioned sectors of
our economy in the future
and that is where inscriptor comes in
with our onyx platform
so this platform enables diverse edit
types
genome-wide and it has a barcode-based
tracking system for easy experimentation
so this is the onyx digital genome
engineering platform
it's not just an instrument it's a whole
platform that comprises of the
instrument
the consumables the essays to measure
phenotypes in your experiments
and also software to design the edits
upstream and to help you interpret the
results downstream
and this is a look of how the onyx
platform
enables researchers to rapidly cycle
through these experimental cycles that
we call
ggtl or design generate test and learn
so starting with the sign on the upper
left corner
the enscripted designer software enables
you to design
thousands of edits that you want to make
in your experiment
based on algorithms that are optimized
the way these
edits are being delivered into the
genome
after you create an order in the
software it kicks off a manufacturing
step
at inscriptor where we generate a custom
set of ready-to-use consumables that are
shipped to you
together with our proprietary
proprietary microfluidics cartridges
and you load these onto the deck of the
onyx instrument together with yourself
the instrument will then run your entire
wet lab part of the experiment for you
the input to the instrument are these
microfluidics cartridges
your custom designed library of edits
all the media and buffer needed and then
also cells
you can use inscriptive standard cells
that we provide with our kit
or you can use your own custom strain as
an input to this editing process
on the instrument the output from the
onyx instrument is a population of
engineered cells
that we call the engineer cell library
let's just zoom in and look at what this
is
this is a diverse pool of edited cells
there is a single cell per edit
and the whole library there can be up to
6000 edits for yeast and up to 10 000
edits for e coli
and the edits can be diverse they can be
insertions deletions or substitutions
up to 63 base pairs in length and there
are also barcodes on the plasmids
that enable you to easily track
enrichment and depletion
in experiments downstream from this pool
of edit itself
so what you do is you take these cells
and you can use them in a diverse range
of experiments that you want to run
you can either plate them out and pick
single colonies and put them into for
example 96 hole plates
to do a direct measurement of a
metabolite or small molecule for example
you can use
mass spec or fluorescent-based readout
or you can also keep the cells in a pool
format
and run a selection where you inoculate
a flask with the pooled library
that you subject to some conditions
under competitive growth
and then you can track enrichment and
depletion of individual designs using
the barcode system
and then after you run your experiments
we have essay kits that help you prepare
ngs samples for sequencing
and after the sequencing the raw fastq
files can be analyzed in our inscriptor
resolver software
which allows you to link genotype to
phenotype and learn from your experiment
which can then be feed into the next
cycle of gttl so the next cycle of
experimentation
enabling you to design new designs based
on what you learned from your first
experiment
so here are some key features of the
onyx platform
it works with both sagger mr ceviche and
e coli
you can use wild type or custom strings
the key
innovation of the technology is that it
uses cell-based partition and
microfluidics
to enable these large-scale libraries
and with really high coverage of all of
the up to 10
000 designs that you have in your
library it has an
optimized editing chemistry including
our proprietary mat 7 nuclease
and the software relies on really
advanced design algorithms
to enable delivery of diverse edit types
to the genome with high efficiencies
and the resolver and designer software
are really easy to use but they're
powerful
and the instrument itself is push button
operation
so it's really easy to do these cycles
of gttl
with just one or two researchers running
the entire cycle
so let's dig a little bit more into some
of the key features of how the onyx
platform works
so one aspect of the platform is the
onyx chemistry
normally when doing crispr experiments
researchers would have to separately add
the guide rna to guide the nucleus to
the correct locus on the genome
and then also add a donor molecule to
drive template mediated repair
so in order to make sure the right guide
rna and donor molecule are being
transformed into the same cell
you need to partition these into for
example 96 wheel plates
but that really limits your throughput
if you are limited by the plate format
so for the onyx platform instead we use
the cells
themselves as the partition so this
enables you to have
thousands of partitions in a single
experiment and the way that this is
accomplished
is by covalently linking together the
guide rna guiding the nucleus
the donor template sequence and a
barcode
to enable easy tracking in your
experiments
i just want to highlight here that it's
only the donor sequence which is
incorporated into the genome
the rest stays on the plasmid
so now for generating these large and
diverse libraries
of different edit types each with
different efficiency
on a single cell format we have to
develop a lot of novel technology
in particular microfluidics to keep the
uniformity of distribution of the
designs in your cell population doing
the editing process
and there are also some other components
to the onyx chemistry including the
guide rna the donor and the barcode
obviously we have them at seven nuclease
to actually make the card
and then repair proteins to help the
cells repair mechanism
they are also supplemented as part of
the onyx chemistry
another key feature of the onyx platform
is the easy to use
software and i'll just show you one
example of that and that is the
inscriptor designer software
which is shown here and there are two
ways that you can make a set of designs
for a library that you want to use in
your experiment
one is by using the graphical user
interface which is easy to learn but
it's very powerful
it allows you to make substitutions
insertions deletions
or do a full saturation mutagenesis on
either a single gene
a set of genes or all genes in your
genome with just a few clicks
you can target specific locations like
inside genes in front of genes or behind
genes
the second way to create a library is by
using our
using the csv file upload this enables
you to make all the same types of
designs and it's friendly with
bioinformatic pipelines
so if you want to use scripting or
informatica design
your libraries that is also very easy to
do
so the software is really easy to use
but it's very powerful because it's
driven by robust algorithms
that power high editing efficiency for
all of the edit designs that you want to
make on the genome
and this is driven by machine learning
models that are built on very large
empirical data sets that we have
collected at inscriptor
so these models have been trained on
more than 300 000 designs
with thousands of features evaluated in
the model and we are continuously
improving these models over time
so in total item scripter we've created
more than 3 million designs and
optimized all of the aspects of
a design the guide the donor the barcode
that
go into the cell to deliver the edits
that you want to make with a really high
efficiency
and this is one of the keys of the onyx
platform is that you can make these
diverse edit types so you can do any
edit that is between 1 and 63 base pairs
in length
insertions deletions or substitutions
and with these algorithms that power our
design software
we are able to target more than 95
percent of the wild type genome
so that means that you can target coding
regions with things like a triple stop
substitution to knock out genes
or do a full saturated mutagenesis of
amino acids
and you can also target non-coding
regions to make regulatory changes in
the genome
like inserting a synthetic promoter rbs
in e coli or synthetic
terminators in yeast so these are just
some examples
and there are essentially infinite ways
that you can manipulate the genome with
this technology
i've just listed a bunch of ideas here
but what i really want you to think
about is
you could do genome-wide truncation
saturation mutagenesis like we already
talked about and we'll also see an
example
a bit later but there are also
many ways to do transcriptional or post
transcriptional regulation so what i
want
you to start thinking about is what
types of libraries
would you design if you had access to a
technology that would allow you
to manipulate your genome with this
scale and ultimately help you understand
how biology works better or engineer
strange with the phenotypes
that you need
so here i show some real life examples
of projects we've run
internally or together with a few of our
early access partners
we've made it easy to alter gene
expression with insertion of a promoter
ladder in front of every gene in the e
coli genome
as well as functional knockouts by
inserting triple sub codons to generate
truncation of proteins
we worked on transcription factor
binding site substitutions in yeast in
order to alter transcription
and thus expression of the genes the
onyx platform makes saturation
mutagenesis of single proteins or even
complete pathways
very easy as we can do up to 10 000
edits per instrument run
and in a minute you will actually see a
real life example of
how that worked we've also
shown with jeff bouquet from nyu how our
technology can be used to quickly debug
strains
in working on creating these synthetic
genomes and finally we've shown that
onyx technology works on improving
heterologous gene expression and
understanding in yeast
so i just want to end my talk with
asking you to think about
which experiments you would perform if
you had access to this kind of
technology
and thank you for your attention and now
i'll turn it over to lizilot de vachter
who will present some amazing data
created on the onyx
platform hi uh
indeed i have been able to test this
technology at a very early stage as an
outsider
and i will share with you my experiences
so if you're listening to this talk
it means that probably you are a life
scientist
and if you are doing research or you
have done some research in the past
chances are that your project would have
looked something like this
you wanted to investigate your favorite
biological phenomenon
and you started with some sort of
screening strategy
now because obviously your screen was
well thought out and it was executed to
perfection
you ended up with a nice number of
significant hits
so the next step was then to prioritize
these hits
think about them deeply and then pick
your favorite one
now this favorite hit you chose is
probably a protein that is not well
characterized
and it is now your life's mission to
fully characterize
everything so you know this protein is
involved in
the process you screened for but how
does this protein perform a catalytic
function and if so where is the
catalytic site and which residues are
involved
perhaps there's a important
protein-protein interaction
and you need to know which residues
mediate this interaction
you even might want to optimize or
change the protein
in some way but also for this you would
need to know which residues are involved
in its function
and what you may want to do to figure
this out and start to answer these
research questions
is to randomly mutagenize the associated
gene for example by error chrome pcr
however there are some important
limitations to this strategy
because error-prone pcr by definition is
random
meaning that you have no way to control
which mutations you will introduce
and there's therefore no way to be sure
that you have targeted all residues in
your protein
and some information may be missed
secondly
by doing error-prone pcr the mutational
space that is available to you
is quite limited because with this
approach
you will introduce usually only one
mutation
per codon meaning that the amount of
amino
acid substitutions that are possible is
limited
take this example shown here on the
slide with a lysine residue
introducing only one point mutation
makes it possible to change
to six different amino acids meaning
that the other 13
are unavailable to test so also here a
lot of information
is lost in an ideal world
you would systematically target your
entire protein
to be sure that you have tested all
residues
on top of that you would replace every
residue with
all different amino acids because some
amino acid
substitutions behave completely
differently
so in short if you would perform a full
saturation mutagenesis on your protein
only then will you be sure that you have
all information
but i think i do not need to tell you
that these are a lot of mutations to
introduce
if you want to saturate just one
position you already need
19 mutations and if you want to do this
for an entire protein
the number of mutations you need is 19
times the length of your protein
meaning that even for short proteins the
number of mutations
easily rises above 2000
now until recently this really was not
worthwhile
no one in their right mind would i think
just set out to create 2 000 different
mutations
but fortunately today this is within the
realm of possibilities
thanks to efforts like the onyx platform
that use high throughput crispr editing
to generate thousands of mutations in
parallel
and just to make sure that we are on the
same page how
the onyx platform does this at least in
e coli is
by introducing two different plasmids
one plasmid encodes the mod 7 nuclease
that will cut the dna and the other
plasmid introduces a very short guide
rna
and a rescue oligo now the rescue alu
oligo is homologous to
the genome and will integrate into the
genome
based on homologous recombination and it
also contains a certain mutation
would you want to get in there
now it's of course easy for any company
to claim that they have
developed this brand new technology that
is capable of generating thousands of
mutants
we were wondering if it if it is
actually true
so we wanted to test this technology and
see if we could use it
to perform saturation methodogenesis and
if it was successful
what kind of information we could get
out of these saturation mutagenesis
libraries
so we chose four different proteins in
the bacterium e coli
to mutate these are lpxa lpxc
mure a and subset and all of these
proteins are involved in synthesis of
the e coli cell envelope
shown here on the left the inner layer
of the cell envelope is the inner
membrane which consists of phospholipids
and phospholipids are created of course
in a multi-step enzymatic
process of which one of the steps is
catalyzed by phosphate
the inner membrane is surrounded by the
peptioglycan which
is a rather thin but very rigid layer
and papuloglycan is produced by among
others mir
a then the most
external layer of the cell envelope is
called the outer membrane
and the outer membrane also contains
phospholipids but besides that it also
has an outer membrane membrane-specific
component
lipopolysaccharides and
lipopolysaccharide or lpf
consists of a core structure which is
called lipid a and this structure
is created by lpxc
we then also added the lpxa protein
which catalyzes a reversible step
that produces and consumes all of the
substrates for these three different
enzymes
and lpxa is therefore thought to access
some kind of hub
in the synthesis of the different cell
envelope layers
now why did we choose these targets well
there are several reasons
first they represent a nice mix between
more and less well-characterized
proteins
meaning that there is information
available in literature that we can use
to validate our findings
using this novel approach but also that
there are still some new discoveries to
be made
and the second reason and perhaps more
importantly is that all of these
proteins are involved in cell envelope
synthesis
and historically the cell envelope has
proven to be one of the most effective
antibiotic targets
out there and you may or may not know
but we are currently on the verge of a
worldwide antibiotic crisis
because more and more bacteria are
becoming resistant to
almost all or even all our current
antibiotics
so we urgently need new compounds
to fight even the most resistant
bacteria
and in this context a lot of effort is
being made into discovering
inhibitors of mostly lpxa and lpxc
these are considered very attractive
targets so we want to fully characterize
these proteins
and try to help this effort
now in our saturation mutagenesis
libraries
we did not just replace every amino acid
with every other amino acid
but for all of these positions we also
included a synonymous mutation
so this synonymous mutation should not
have an influence at the protein level
but
it does introduce a change in the dna
which we can
track through sequencing and so for us
this is an important quality control
which i will discuss
in a few minutes but this means that for
every residue
in the proteins we have created 20
different
edits and this brings us to a total of
almost
23 000 different eddies that we were
able to create
just like that and how did this
practically work well
we created the four different libraries
completely separately from one another
for all of them we started from the same
e coli wild-type bacterium
and the correct plasmids were then
transformed of course with this
microfluidics platform that you have
heard about
and this generated for us the different
mutated libraries now of course because
crispr editing is not 100
efficient our mutated library still
contains some wild type cells
but fortunately we also have a high
enough percentage
of edited cells that contain the desired
mutations
we then did with these libraries was
simply sequence the genes that were
supposed to be mutated
to detect which mutation mutations were
actually present
and at this point it's very important
for you to know that all four
of these proteins and their associated
genes
are essential for e coli viability
so this means that if we introduce a
mutation for example in lpxa
that abolishes protein function this
specific mutant will die
and it will disappear from the library
and we will not find it when we sequence
this gene
on the other hand if we introduce a
mutation that does not interfere with
protein function
this mutant survives we sequence it and
we detect the mutation in question
and so by looking at which edits are and
are not present
among our sequenced reads we hope to be
able to define
which residues of these proteins are
essential for their function
but before i can address this research
question we were of course
wondering if the saturated metagenesis
libraries that were created by the onyx
platform
we're of sufficient quality to try and
answer this question
so as a first step we did some quality
control
and the first thing we did was look at
if there were any residues in these
proteins that simply could not be
targeted
by the technology for example because
bam sites were too inefficient or any
other
reason and
these uneditable residues or residues
that cannot be changed to any other
amino acid
but for which we also could not
introduce a synonymous mutation
are indicated here with white lines
so unfortunately we do find an editable
residues
that simply cannot be targeted but
fortunately their number is quite
low we have a maximum
of five different uneditable residues
that cannot be mutated due to
technological reasons
and i say it's a maximum because i
actually believe
that some of these residues are in this
list
simply due to biological reasons for
example if you look at the methionine at
position
1 in the mirror a enzyme i think this is
purely biological
that it's it occurs here because of
course this methionine is encoded by
start codon
and in this case the start codon that is
being used is the most efficient one
meaning that any mutation of this codom
would lead to either a complete
inhibition
of translation or at least a lower
translation
efficiency and so a lower amount of the
a protein and therefore lowered
viability
but so i have of course no way to prove
that this is the case so to be on the
safe side we say that these residues
are uneditable
still i think 5 is a reasonable number
to work with so we then
went on to the next stage which was to
ask ourselves the questions
if these libraries are actually fully
saturated
now fully saturated would mean that all
of the 19 amino acid substitutions that
we created per position
would also be created and would be
introduced into the genome
meaning that the maximum level of 19
would be reached here
throughout the protein but of course for
an essential protein such as lpxc
this is not this is not what we expect
because even if we introduce if we are
able to introduce some of these
mutations in the genome
they will disappear because they do not
support viability
so in the case of essential genes and
essential proteins this is not a way to
evaluate saturation
so to do this in a different way we
looked at only synonymous mutations
the reason being that synonymous
mutations should not change anything at
the protein level
so in theory we should be able to
introduce them
into the genome without affecting
viability
meaning that if a synonymous mutation is
absent it's probably
because the library is not fully
saturated
and so here you can see that the
synonymous mutations that are absent
represented by white lines do quite
frequently occur
if we compare the number of missing
synonymous mutations
with the number of synonymous mutations
that we do detect
we'd see that for all libraries the
saturation level is around
90 so definitely it's not perfect
perfect would be 100
but still 90 i would argue is quite high
what does it actually mean this 90
saturation level
well it means that the probability that
any one specific mutation is missing
from the sequencing pool
just due to random chance is 10
and this is quite high but remember that
for every position we designed
19 different amino acid substitutions
and the probability of
all amino acid changes missing for one
specific position
actually becomes very very low it's 10
to the minus
19 meaning that it this will not just
happen by random chance
and that if we find positions for which
this is the case
there's most likely a biological
explanation
so i believe with this 90 saturation
level and the numbers
i have presented just now i think it's
safe to say that we can use these
libraries
to try and determine which residues are
essential for protein function
and this is exactly what we are going to
do now
so to try and not bore you to death i
will limit this discussion to only one
of the libraries the lpxc library
and just as a reminder mander lpxc
catalyzes the first committed step
in the production of lipid a which is an
essential component of the outer
membrane
of e coli and what you see here in this
big plot
is basically all information we have for
this library
on the x-axis you see the position in
the lpxc protein
and on the y-axis you see by which amino
acids
this position can be occupied
if there is a white line it means that
this specific amino acid could not be
found
at this specific position if the line is
blue it means that we did find it
and the darker the shade of blue the
more frequently we encounter this
and now what we are looking for are
positions in lpxc for which
a white line occurs vertically
because these positions cannot be
changed to a lot of amino acids
now if you squint your eyes a little bit
i think you will be able to see
a very clear one in between position 180
and 200
and if you would look in more detail
there are a couple of others that you
can discover
but to make your life and also my life
more easy let's look at the data like
this
so what you now see on the y-axis is the
number of
successful amino acid substitutions
if this number is 19 it means that at
this position
all different amino acids are tolerated
and this plot it's more easy to see
which
residues are actually essential
but this brings me to i think rather a
complex discussion
because if we want to define which
residues are essential
we need a definition for essentiality
and i think this is something you can
discuss about and i think several
different definitions
can be put forward but something i
believe
no one could disagree with is that a
residue
must be essential if it cannot be
mutated to
anything else and i believe this is the
most strict definition of essentiality
that you could come up with
and the residues that conform to this
definition we call them
absolutely essential and these residues
are the ones that have a
value of zero in the plot on the left
so here in this table you can see all of
these absolutely essential residues
we define with our new approach
of course the first question is are
these residues indeed essential
and so to answer this question i dived
into literature and looked what was
already known for the lpxc
protein and here shaded in gray
are the residues that we know from
literature are indeed essential
so hooray for us because indeed a lot of
the residues we identify here
are of course correct
and at this point i want to discuss the
last residue in the list a little bit
further
this h265 residue because if you have
been paying
incredibly close attention you might
remember that this was
also one of the uneditable residues i
discussed before
and so also for this residue i now
believe that there is a biological
explanation why we find it as
uneditable we know from literature that
it is essential
explaining why no amino acid
substitution could be found
and i believe the reason that we do not
find this synonymous mutation
for this 265 residue is simply
because of pure luck remember that the
chance of any one specific mutation
missing from our library
is as high as 10 percent
in any case i think this list shows that
indeed our approach is capable to
capture information
that is biologically relevant and
importantly
we also identify some new residues here
residues that were not previously known
to be essential
and this is very exciting to us of
course
this leaves a question are these new
residues indeed essential
and so to try and build some confidence
in our method
we plotted these residues on the lpxc
crystal structure
and then you see that all of these
absolutely essential residues
shown on the protein in blue they all
group together
in and around the protein's active site
so this gives us a lot of confidence
that also the newly identified residues
are indeed essential for protein
function
so far so good but at this point we
realize that our definition of
essentiality we use so far
is actually too strict because in
literature there are two
other residues that are known to be
essential and
we do not find these residues here
so we went back to this type of plot and
then if you take some time to look for
residue 78
and also some time to look for the
residue at position 238
you will see that both of them indeed
can mutate
to different amino acids but only to one
other amino acid
and if we go and take a look at which
amino acid this actually is
it's uh it's an amino acid that has
a very similar properties to the
original amino acid that is present
so meaning that some residues that can
be replaced by other amino acids
can still be essential which is why we
expanded our definition a bit and we
now also define potentially essential
residues
and we say that these residues they can
still mutate to other
amino acids but only to a very small
number
and for now we put the threshold f3
and then we generate this new list of
potentially essential residues
that now also include the two residues
that were missing
before also very interesting to see
is that we now include these residues
that are shaded in some darker gray
that were not described to be essential
for protein function but that we do know
are involved in substrate binding and so
therefore are probably
important for lpxt
and once again we also find a lot of new
ones which we are very excited about
to explore further also if we plot these
potentially essential
residues on the protein structure they
are shown down in orange
you see that a lot of them group around
the active site
some of them are located elsewhere in
the protein does this mean that they are
for sure not essential
i think no i think for these we have to
go and manually check if this is the
case
and for example i want to highlight the
residue on the far
left in orange which is as far
from the active site as you can get but
still i believe this residue is for sure
essential because this
is actually the methionine at position
1.
so in this case for lpxc this methionine
the start column that encodes it can
still be mutated to
some other alternative and less
efficient start codons
but definitely not to a lot of different
ones explaining
why we listed as a potentially essential
residue
so to formulate a conclusion to this
part of my presentation
i would say that the onyx platform was
quite capable
of of generating the saturation
mutagenesis library
where we get a saturation level of as
high as 90 percent
which i believe is quite impressive and
is definitely high enough
to start and identify essential residues
and indeed we have successfully used it
to identify residues that are involved
in catalysis
of the lpxc protein and also in
substrate binding
and although this does not apply for
lpxc which
functions in isolation i strongly
believe that the same approach can be
used
to identify protein-protein interactions
and allosteric regulation sites
if this applies to your favorite protein
now obviously this new information we
discovered we want to use it
to extend insights into protein function
and hopefully support in the design of
lpxc targeting drugs
and now before i end my talk i want to
talk about this data a little more but
from a completely different perspective
because while looking at plots like this
which you've seen already a lot now
i realized that in fact there are a lot
of positions
in the protein that will accept just any
amino acid and i used to think of
proteins
as these molecular machines that
were fine-tuned to perfection
by millions of years of evolution and
that even the slightest
change would lower the efficiency of
this protein
but perhaps this was kind of a naive
view because
clearly it is not the case and this
becomes even more clear
when we plot this information like this
so what you see here is not just
information from the lpxc library
but actually from all libraries we have
and on the x-axis you see
the number of successful amino acid
substitutions
at any one position and then you see
that in over
40 of all positions
the amino acid that is present can be
replaced by
anything or at least all but one amino
acid
which to me was quite surprising and it
highlights the
high flexibility that any one position
has
in the amino acid tolerance
but of course this is a very global view
we can zoom in a bit more
previously i've urged you to look at
this plot
vertically but of course we can turn it
around
and if you look horizontally i think one
thing that will pop out
obviously is that the proline residue is
not well accepted because it has a lot
of white lines
there and of course indeed this is known
from literature
and we can capture it also more clearly
when we change the plot
so here you see that proline the one in
orange indeed performs the worst
in less than half of all cases proline
insertion into a protein is accepted
meaning that in more than half of all
cases if you insert a protein into a
if if you insert a proline excuse me
into the protein
you will render the protein
dysfunctional
and proline performs the worst and the
second worst is arginine
of course there's also the other side of
the spectrum with alanine performing the
best and 16 being a close
second for us now of course there's
much more information to be gained out
of this for example we could look at
these
success rates of amino acid
incorporation
in function of the secondary structure
or how it behaves differently in the
different libraries
and this these are of course all things
we are doing
so if i can give you one take-home
message from this presentation
i think it should be that the saturation
mutagenesis library simply contain
a ton of information that is highly
interesting
and is a lot of fun to play around with
and
because it contains so much information
i think it's
a very nice starting point for the
characterization
of any protein for example
also your favorite protein and with that
i
would like to close my talk and uh thank
the people that
were involved in this project and of
course
uh the people who gave us the people who
gave me money
so with that i will stop talking and if
you have any questions we are very happy
to answer them
answer them
[Music]
and thank you so much dr dewacher and
dr clinton for that informative
presentation
and we will now start the live q a
portion of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for so let's
get started we already have some great
questions coming in from our audience
members
our first question how is inscripta
advising customers as to how to handle
the pull of edited
cells once it comes off the instrument
yeah so okay thanks this is laura here i
can take that
question so obviously it's very
important when you have
this pool and i think you might have to
unmute because we don't hear you
i am unusual i'm trying to answer
hello hello can you hear me do you hear
me now
hello and
again hello i want to thank our audience
do you hear me oh perfect you hear me
okay now
okay so i will i will ask i will answer
the question as
good as again so basically um
basically what you have to remember is
now you're working with libraries
and your edits will be different so
basically
um the different edits that you're now
generating
need to be very cautious of working with
this library so we do have also offer uh
guidance for how to work with this
library to make sure you have the right
distribution of your library
when you work downstream uh with
yourself so we are offering guidance for
how to handle these sales uh
downstream of the editing
our next question does the onyx system
support
editing on plasmids
yeah so i can take that as well this is
lower here so
great question so uh this is a genome
engineering platform so
the onyx is working on the genome level
so right now this is not uh it's not
something we do we don't edit on the
plasmids
but we do we do that on the genome so
the advantage of having that is that
you're not introducing as such a
platform that you need to maintain
further downstream when you're working
with yourself you're actually
introducing the
the edits right on the genome so that
you have already
incorporated at the specific place and
the specific locus where you want it
already from the start
thank you so much these are great
questions coming in
by our audience members now tell me what
exactly
does a barcode do can you please
elaborate on that for our audience
yeah so i can take that as well yes a
great question so basically the barcode
enables you to very quickly
and very easily track what's going on in
your cell population
so the barcode is is located on the
plasmid
so as long as you maintain the plasmid
inside the cells
then you will be able to use this as a
process of what's happening on the
genome level
and this enables you to very quickly for
example if you're
doing like pools growth selection
if you want to look at a growth
phenotype then you would actually know
very quickly by looking at the barcodes
which cells were enriched and which
cells were depleted so which edits were
actually beneficial
for my specific phenotype and which were
detrimental for the phenotype
so the barcode is really giving you a
very
very like easy access to a lot of very
valuable
information so that you can start like
digging into the data
very quickly from running these
experiments
thank you so much now our next question
what percentage of a library pool is
unchanged plasmid
so i'm not completely sure i
understand this question
i think i'll have to answer that uh
like by email because i need to dig a
little bit what
probably meant or maybe the the person
who asked the question can like
elaborate a bit on on what's meant by
this
um because
we do we do use a plastic system to do
the edits but the edits are done on this
genome so i'm not really sure what's
meant with
like unchanged plasmids sorry
thank you very much these are great
questions
we have time for a few more now how long
an experiment such as the one by elisa
lot take
um so yeah let me answer this um
so it depends of course on what you're
talking about if it's
just the editing i mean using the onyx
platform
um i'm not 100 sure but i think
now this is definitely done in a couple
of days
and then after the editing all we
basically did was
grow the libraries and then sequence
them and
um obviously this can go quite quickly
with illumina sequencing and then
everything just depends on how fast and
how well you can analyze your data
so i think really if everything is
optimized and streamlined in a week you
have your data
thank you again now your http
technology generates a lot of samples
it would be difficult to process all the
samples do you have
htp solution for enzyme expression
and assay yeah so
thanks i can take that question so um
inscriptor does not we don't like
provide sounds
in the testing capacity but we do
acknowledge it's very important when
running these big libraries that you
need to balance
your generate and the test and we do
also have some guidance on how to best
do that
but it's basically also a matter of
discussing
what's the specific project you want to
do what you're aiming for this project
what you want to achieve and then
find the best downstream solution to
actually
do the either screening or selection or
to monitor
the different uh genotypes you had and
look at the phenotype so
so it's a great question it's very
important to look at the whole
experiment
and balance those two uh like the build
and the test part of your experiment
definitely
[Music]
thank you again now will this platform
be available for human cells anytime
soon
interesting question yeah so uh
yeah i can take that as well so onyx is
has been developed for microbial systems
so this is a microbial platform
that works with e coli and sarcomere
inscripta is working on a mammalian
system
uh that's that has been um announced
previously and i unfortunately can't
share more details about that but you
have to
follow inscriptions on social media and
and look at our website for when uh we
can share
more details uh about yesterday
yeah but onyx is for microbial
our next audience question
is asked i'm very surprised that the
cystine
substitution is tolerated is it possible
that it is not true for
all proteins um
it's i think it's definitely possible
already when we look at
our four different libraries we see that
there are some differences
between them um however cysteine for
all or all of our four libraries
do pops up as one of the best uh
tolerated amino acids
so why is this the case uh obviously i
don't know but it's just what we see
and and what is happening and what's
biologically tolerated apparently
thank you very much now did you try
multiple
synopsis mutations at the 265 site to
make sure that the site is not simply
let's say uneditable yes so
before we started obviously we did not
know that this would be
a problem to to edit this position
now in retrospect of course we wish we
would have included a couple
other synonymous mutations
we will not repeat the whole library
editing process
but we will go in manually to try and
change this site
to a synonymous mutation just this one
mutation and see if it works
and i'm quite confident that we will be
able to make a synonymous mutation yes
thank you very much and i want to thank
our audience for these great questions
we have time for about three more
questions before we close today
this next audience member says thank you
so much for your great presentation
do you have any explanation for why
proteins are more or less tolerant
for certain amino acid substitutions
example pro arg versus cis
uh yes so uh for example if i take the
most
the most clear example i think uh of the
proline residue
it has a very specific structure it
really does not look
like any of the other amino acids so
it is also known to break up like alpha
helices
and beta structures so it is it seems
quite logical that when we introduce a
proline into
a protein at a random position that it
has a higher chance
of disturbing protein function
from the other hand for example alanine
has a very
let's say modest structure so it's
probably tolerated better
of course if you have a an amino acid
that performs for example a catalytic
function
as uh proton donor or whatever um
probably alanine would also not not work
very well
but in general uh speaking this is
better tolerated yes
thank you very much now are there
residues
that are highly tolerant of changes
also the most variable across population
of e coli
or other bacterial species
i think that's a very interesting
question that we are
also asking ourselves but unfortunately
we are
not yet at the stage in the project
where we have examined this
uh but i think it's it's a very good
remark and i
i believe that the most tolerant
positions would also be the most
variable
but until we go look at it there's no
way to be sure
thank you very much now how do we know a
residue affects
protein function or just affects protein
folding process and causes a low
expression level
when the mutant was eliminated from the
selection
[Music]
well i believe if it if a mutation
changes protein folding or protein
expression it kind of also changes
protein function
uh but i get of course the question
you're looking for
residues that are more directly involved
in
functioning of protein for example
catalytic residues
and so i think just by looking if a
mutant is present yes or no
there's really no way to say
but i think a more more in-depth
downstream analysis can answer this
question so looking at whether or not
this residue is located at the active
site uh
if it's located at surface of the
protein or more uh
inside the protein of course if it's
really very deep inside the protein most
likely
it's about protein folding etc
and this is our last question we have
time for
and it's a clarification of the previous
question in the final mutation
pool what percentage of cells do not
have
a change in the target in other words
what percentage of cells
do not have a variant okay great
yeah i don't have lower i can take that
so
basically i think this kind of follow up
for the from the test
question so of course it's important to
think about that you're introducing a
plasmid into the cell
and then when the plasmid is there so
there's like an additive efficiency of
transformation efficiency
and actually the onyx is very very has a
very
high transformation efficiency
approaching almost 100
so basically all cells will have a
plasmid and this is because of the
microfluidics that we developed that
this is so high
so that's kind of solved and then of
course you also have the actual editing
which will happen on the genome
and and obviously there will be some
that are
kind of unedited or some will have
what we call like not complete or
because we
we work with the terminology of onyx
edits which is complete and intended
so this means that the design and the
edit that happened would have to be
exactly as designed in the encrypter
designer software so there will be a
percentage of cells that
will have this and then we have a
percentage of cells that
have like wild type on the genome and
the specification for the onyx platform
is that we see
30 or more like the fraction of cells
that has a complete and intended
edit that is 30 or more but often we see
a high as up to like 75
of the cells but i would really if you
are interested to know more about the
specifics of the technology and uh
and uh and how this actually works and
how to work with this
um stream please go to our website and
also
uh contact us to get more information on
the specifics of these
matters
thank you so much dr jay wachter dr
clinton do you have any
final comments for our audience before
we go dr clinton i'll start with you
yeah okay thanks so i just want to say
thank you so much
uh for for attending uh this uh this
webinar today and please
don't hesitate to reach out to me if you
have any questions whatsoever
i'm happy to help also set up follow-up
calls
and and go to the encrypted website and
and you can see a lot of the great
resources
we have there for more detailed
information
yeah so that's all for me i don't know
if you have any final comments please a
lot you want to
share i just i was very excited to be
able to test this technology
and i think we really got some very very
nice data
out of it and i'm very enthusiastic
about it yes
thank you so much and dr walker would
you like to add
some final comments uh no i'll leave
without this
oh thank you so much i apologize thank
you again
i want to thank you both for your time
today and for your important research
and i'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor inscripta for underwriting
today's
educational webcast and before i want to
thank our live audience for joining us
today
and for their interesting questions just
as a reminder questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email
once available for replay we encourage
you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time stay safe stay safe and
stay healthy bye bye everyone